[Music]
hello there we're back again with more
dc comic book goodness before we start a
quick reminder that this is a
continuation of the zero point storyline
i'll link the full breakdown of each
episode if you want to be totally up to
date on how batman went to and got back
from our little fortnite island the only
thing you need to know right away is
that io are responsible for the rift on
the streets outside led by dr sloan she
is working in partnership with lex
luthor and the batman who laughs let's
do this owen code adamaru pretty please
[Music]
the story kicks off with the justice
league fighting a swarm of dc villains
we quickly determine they are fighting
over a tear in reality a gaping hole a
rift in metropolis just like those we
saw agent jones create in season 5. as
we all know the zero point is a gateway
to other dimensions and batman quickly
reminds us going through to our island
will result in superman losing his
memory and speech and even his
superhuman abilities the villains the
justice league are fighting are trying
to get into that rift they want to go to
the island for some reason wonder woman
is happy letting them go but batman
states the fact they are trying to get
to it tells me it's crucial we stop them
as the flash enters the battle he lets
us know lex luthor in his power suit and
the batman who laugh are no longer
controlling things from the shadows they
are upfront getting personal and part of
this battle flash confirms that the
batman who laughs is actually already
dead it turns out wonder woman killed
him with a chainsaw well that is dark
but hey he's back alive again now and
that's not the end of the revelations
that swirling line you see there that's
actually plastic man a rubberized
superhero
it turns out that batman is not in
metropolis with the rest of the crew
he's still in gotham and instead travels
to the rift in his hometown thinking
that this must be a decoy
suddenly we cut back in time just a few
minutes at the docks of gotham harbour a
mysterious figure leaves the water it's
the foundation we last saw him fall
through the zero point months ago his
first word in dc comic book history is
the greatest you'll ever hear he says
yep that's his first line ever
we get a great piece of law on the next
few panels which explain how all this
happened during the zero point crisis
the foundation sealed himself into the
zero point to protect reality from
destruction he was essentially like a
medic giving the zero point the time it
needed to heal itself after all the
times agent johnsy overused that orb it
needed a break but before it was
completely fixed an alien mothership of
the last reality attached to the spire
it's still unclear if this was a
destruction attempt or an endeavor to
steal the zero point away what we do
know is that the foundation fell through
the zero point exiting the time stream
at the last place on record which was
gotham city arising from the harbour
water foundation and batman meet
batman's on home turf and goes with the
tough guy routine
you're going to tell me who you are
how you got here
and what you think you're doing in my
city
very intimidating betsy yet foundation
isn't bothered in the slightest and
flies away i'm the rock i mean i'm the
foundation he says and i have no time
for you or your filthy city batman takes
this personally and connects the
foundation's foot to the batmobile
bringing him back down to earth the
fight goes on for pages and pages with
no man getting the overall upper edge
remember the fight with agent jones and
all of a sudden he stopped when he heard
the word geno
i can get you to geno
this time the code word is zero point
suddenly the foundation wants to be
allies with batman you know about the
zero point you've been there batman
admits to being there recently and tells
of an organization that manipulates the
island foundation says it how it is
they're called the imagined order and
it's safe to say we are enemies suddenly
the enemy of an enemy just became a
friend foundation hits us with more
facts which for law hunters like you and
i are desperately needed foundation is
confirmed to be the leader of the seven
with a simple mission statement to stop
the imagined order and liberate the zero
point destroying the loop forever io are
said to be messing with countless lives
in the pursuit of knowledge and power
that explains all the items locked away
when batman visited the underground
bunkers all items from multiple
realities taken without consent the pair
agreed to go to the new rift over in
metropolis and the road trip begins
[Music]
as the two arrive at metropolis batman
has just finished telling his story of
how he closed the rift to gotham with a
perfectly timed explosive batarang
foundation makes a very interesting
remark about batman working for io
stating most who do don't even realize
it which is exactly what happened to
batman as he was recruited by lex and co
to find a way out of the loop which he
did without realizing foundation has
more law to tell us explaining the dawn
of time in the beginning there was
nothing then in a burst of pure creation
the zero point sprang into being
countless realities created in an
instant with its own universe and
multiverse attached never to no more
than that but there is one more above
the multiverse called the omniverse he
mentions it once and we never hear it
again almost as soon as the zero point
was created io began manipulating
realities to learn the secrets of the
multiverse traveling to and from them on
a whim the only way to do this is with a
pure portal the same thing jonesy used
at the start of season five and the very
same one batman used to get home so we
can stop calling this room the zero
point room it's now a pure portal but
there is in fact a second way those
riffs we see all the time the tears in
reality directly link one world to
another and get this they refer to these
as sideways rifts which coincidentally
is the name given to the demonic world
we visit in game right now when
approaching one of these the sideways
the cracks in reality can only heal
naturally according to the foundation
time heals all wounds i suppose
it turns out io were forced to make this
rift after the foundation cocooned
himself away blocking the use of the
pure portal and that's when batman
realizes he was used by io and his arch
enemies to make this rift in metropolis
a reality batman got played the plan now
is simple to stop io and the dc villains
from claiming the island and the pure
portal within it batman and foundation
must use a new weapon never seen before
it looks like a slime block on a rift
gun and just as the foundation tells us
what it does they're attacked by chemo a
failed science experiment designed to
cure famine i love dc comic books the
foundation yeets him into space because
he's just that cool and speeds back down
towards the open rift edging closer he
is shot out of the sky by lex luthor
there's another fight in the air before
the foundation karate chops the helmet
of lex cracking it
this is quite interesting the theory is
that self-contained suits like that lex
and the foundation and other members of
the seven wear prevent the loop from
affecting their minds a sealed suit
keeps the user's voice thoughts and
memories intact but a simple crack would
undo all of this it looks like luther's
plan was to stay inside his suit and
enter the loop and now that plan is in
tatters the foundation and batman
attempt to meet during the fight but
with so many shape-shifters on the field
foundation is forced to use a scan to
identify batman it works but the thing
is there's more than one batman and
instead he chooses the batman who laughs
this wrong decision leads to the
foundation taking an rko out of nowhere
[Applause]
the batman who laughs is now diving
straight into the rift forcing
foundation to follow closely behind
[Music]
the foundation and the batman who laughs
crash down on the island there isn't
much time left until the loop resets
foundation calls the real batman but
without warning is attacked by the one
who chuckles it's another fight scene
this one ends with the batman who laughs
cracking the helmet of the foundation
using the center spike on his snm visor
without his armor in tip-top condition
at the end of the next loop the
foundation will be powerless to resist
the island's overwhelming force like
we've seen so many times over the years
he will lose his voice he will lose his
memories he'll be stuck here like the
rest of us foundation gets a bit angry
and reroutes power to his gauntlets
shouting about geno a person or group
we've only heard of once before
i can get you to geno
it turns out that geno is the one
controlling the zero point which likely
means they are part of io in a high
position maybe who could geno be i still
like the thought that he's the guy in
this picture with sloane and i really
hope his first name is dave dave geno
would be the coolest villain name ever
if you have any theories about geno
please shove them in the comments a
defeated batman who laughs watches as
the storm circle closes in his final few
moments the foundation contacts the real
batman in metropolis and they trigger
the device together it worked the rift
became vapor and a sound was heard which
could only be described as zwash the
plan works the heroes are victorious but
no this isn't over lex begins plan b a
force field covers the justice league
allowing all the villains to escape how
convenient batman tells us that knowing
that the other batman the one that
laughs is stuck on the island is the
perfect prison for that maniac anyone he
kills will live again minutes later and
eventually the batman who laughs will
lose his mind and all his memories this
is a win-win situation for bruce wayne
but plot twist the foundation is totally
fine without realizing he was at the
center of the final storm circle and the
final survivor he now lives on the
island outside the loop and off he pops
to find io meanwhile in the next loop
the batman who laughs is having the time
of his life we see him murder a tomato
and everyone be honest right now who
thought this guy was wearing a tomato
mask
i certainly did well it turns out he
really had a tomato for a head
fortnite joker's visor sorry i mean the
batman who laughs visor is made from the
world forge which is the realm of dark
matter in the dc world the sheer energy
of that thing is strong enough to fight
off the loop's effects and keeps this
batman's memories all intact he wonders
about snapshots and if he could make a
conga line of the batman who laugh so i
did it for him good call finally we hear
the batman who laughs tell us why he's
really here i've devoted my life to
corrupting different universes i won't
be limited to one multiverse anymore and
that's how it ends to be continued the
batman who laughs doesn't want a
universe he doesn't want a multiverse
he's going for the full omniverse
corrupting every reality he comes in
contact with and that's where we're at
after this one-off comic book there's
lots more to delve into next time we'll
figure out what on earth the omniverse
is a quick thank you to those who use
code adamarros this week is dedicated to
the discord members thank you very much
i'm adam you're awesome i'll see you
again very soon